you don't remember what we were talking
about nope not a clue what were we
talking about
some actors are so good their
improvisation and ad-libs end up making
the final cut of a film
and oftentimes they can make for some of
the best scenes
we don't typically think of animated
movies having that much improvisation
which is why these off-script scenes
totally shocked us
which actor improvised more than 80 of
their dialogue
how about the on-the-spot vanity of an
evil sidekick which actor was so in tune
with their character
they actually forgot which lines they
ad-libbed hey guys
that was a long minute huh in the
live-action version of aladdin there was
very little room or time for ad-libbing
so it was quite a surprise to have
almost a
full scene improvised by the actors
remember when the genie and prince ali
meet the royal family for the first time
actor mina masood said that the
improvising came easy working opposite
will smith and that the experience was
really special
the scene was actually improvised from
start to finish
don't touch me don't touch me we loved
what we saw on screen so it definitely
worked out for the best
well yes
one of the funnier and uh weirder
moments in the live-action beauty and
the beast was
definitely lefou's counseling gaston to
his happy place with whispers of
fighting and explosions
blood explosions countless widows
if it seems like a bit of an odd line
for a disney film to write
then you'd be right because it isn't a
line from the script at
all josh gad made it up on the spot
based on a plan he and luke evans had
come up with prior to shooting
the two collaborated and came up with
this wacky idea of what would comgast on
down since
he was most comfortable as himself on
the battlefield well what we heard was
pretty crazy
there were even wilder lines that came
up in the ad-lib
deep breaths gaston deep breaths
so olaf probably has one of the best
introduction lines there ever was
hi everyone i'm olaf and i like warm
hugs
could he be any sweeter what makes it
even better is knowing that all the
charm was pure josh gad as he improvised
the line
hi i'm olaf and i like warm hugs
it was a perfect fit for the extremely
lovable and notoriously funny snowman
yeah that's so funny i don't have a
skull
another stellar josh gad improv line
came when uh
well this happened his ad-lib
oh look at that i've been impaled
is pretty perfect and what's more is
that it actually started as a joke
god jokingly said it while recording and
the team loved it so much they decided
to create this glorious animation
it definitely took the actor by surprise
when he watched the film because he
didn't think they'd actually use it
we're definitely glad they did just put
it in
the randomness will work never thinking
that they would actually do it
loads of the dialogue between timon and
pumbaa from the live-action lion king
film was actually improvised by seth
rogen and billy eichner
the first day recording was actually
spent improvising all the timon and
pumbaa scenes
an absolute gem that came from these
ad-libs was when seth rogen commented
that the bugs they were eating were all
local
extra crunchy they're local yeah oh are
they they're from right there
timon's many zingers were one of the
best parts of the lion king
one in particular really made the iconic
hakuna matata scene better than we could
have imagined
remember when timon said i was always
here for you and i resent that
it's not too much of a shocker to know
that that wasn't in the script but a
brilliant ad-lib from eichner
robin williams is famous for improvising
the majority of his genie in the
animated version of aladdin
he was the genie and the genie was him
so much so that about 80 to 90 percent
of all the dialogue in the movie was
actually ad-libbed one of the best
disney references comes from the genie
we're of course referring to the
pinocchio bit i'll do it
i'll set you free uh-huh yeah right
[Applause]
williams was riffing in a recording
session and the animators thought it was
genius so they added it in
we wonder how many bits of gold didn't
actually make the cut kind of pushing
the boundaries
of disney animation which is great if it
didn't seem like a line scripted by
disney
that's because it wasn't nathan lane was
the one who came up with
what do you want me to do dress and drag
and do the hula and are we
ever glad he did it's a great line but
honestly kind of surprising disney would
have kept it in the film
especially at the time thank goodness it
was included because it's actually what
inspired the timon and pumba luau scene
oh no are you kidding me i don't have my
wallet
remember the amazing hustle shown off by
our favorite fox nick wilde
you liar it's called a hustle well this
lost wallet bit in zootopia
actually came from an improvisation
jason bateman had done the scene in a
few different ways while recording and
they varied in range
wildly even one very melodramatic
version
sly fox dumb bunny how could anyone
forget iago
jafar's parrot sidekick the actor who
voiced the bird gilbert gaffried
improvised
loads while he was in the recording
booth and sometimes even went so far
that the team had to remind him to pull
back because after all
it is a children's film one of his
absolute best one-liners is definitely
here when he takes a while contemplating
over the picture of himself in jafar
and uh how about this picture i don't
know i think i'm making a weird face in
it
we wonder how many improvised gems
didn't end up making the cut
finding dory gave us all the dory we
wanted ellen degeneres's interpretation
and portrayal of the forgetful fish was
incredible
and her instincts spot on dory is
notorious for asking lots of questions
and talking at the speed of light
when she isn't speaking whale that is
one of the funniest was definitely when
she said how can you do this park in one
day seriously okay
it's a pretty perfect dory line and
reminds us just how lovable a character
she is
there actually wasn't a ton of room for
improvising throughout the recording
process within too many scenes
so for the most part degeneres just
threw in a little ad-lib line here and
there
her improvs were so in line with the
character that sometimes
she didn't even remember she was the one
that thought of them
what tag there's a oh there's a tag on
my fin
one moment in cinema history that has
never gotten old is
definitely nemo's pronunciation of
the topic of an anemone wound up being a
great point of conversation since it
also proved useful for marlin's failed
delivery of a joke
the sea cucumber looks over the mollusk
and says with friends like these who
needs anemones
this hilarious delivery was thanks to
some improvisation from albert brooks
he spent the whole day in the studio
ad-libbing that joke and didn't mess it
up the same way
once we would have loved to hear all the
other improv mangled joke tellings
and then the sea cucumber well they are
mixed up
anyone remember cogsworth's clever and
memorable remark from the animated
beauty and the beast film
the line flowers chocolates promises you
don't intend to keep
was actually made up on the spot by
actor david ogden steyers
this is a pretty perfect ad-lib
moana was filled with so many great
characters and hilarious lines but
we have to give props to by far the
shiniest character
tamatoa remember that clever reference
to sebastian
if my name was sebastian and i had a
cool jamaican accent you totally helped
me
well the idea itself was written in by
jared bush but the majority of the lines
themselves were pretty much
made up on the spot by germain clement
he had ad-libbed a few other golden
moments but
unfortunately not all the gold could
make the cut still upside down here
just need a little push ever wonder how
the mad hatter in the animated version
of alice in wonderland felt like such a
real person
well it's probably because the character
we see of the mad hatter is actually
based on the actor who portrayed him
edwin wynn was notorious for ad-libbing
and one day he came up with the watch
repairing bit and walt disney overheard
it
he loved it so much that he thought it
should be in the final cut of the film
the trouble was it hadn't been recorded
with great quality since it was just a
riff but
walt didn't care he made sure it was in
the final cut
we'll have to look into this
after seeing all these brilliant moments
it just goes to show
how well cast all these actors were
these movies
definitely wouldn't have been the same
with other actors which improv moment
surprised you the most